ah les
téméraires
ben entreprenons
je suis ni règne donc j'ai
je suis marié j'ai deux grands garçons
et je vis à la rivière saint-louis et
travaille à l'arrivée à saint louis avec
une association pour gérer des
prestations pédagogiques pour les écoles
surtout pour les écoles
le matin avant de que les enfants
arrivent c'est très calme on entend les
oiseaux on entend le poney on attendre
les canards les chèvres mais dans deux
heures on va entendre à les rires des
enfants ce projet je pense que c'est un
petit peu un aboutissement d'un parcours
professionnel au départ au niveau du
parcours pour moi c'était bon comme
j'étais éducatrice spécialisée je
travaillais donc avec les enfants et en
vers la quarantaine j'ai voulu allier
deux choses qui me tenait à coeur est
entré très militante dans l'âme j'avais
par rapport à mes convictions pouvoir
les développer en mettant en place
vraiment quelque chose qui correspond au
fond de moi ce que j'avais vraiment
envie et allié le travail éducation à
l'environnement avec les enfants
john
tu es là bonjour
en fait connu
et bien moi je suis là où vous êtes dans
mon atelier parce que je suis artiste
plasticien donc voilà je
christie siens la ferme plasticien la
ferme je suis agriculteur pour une fois
là on est dans une ferme où le l'homme
n'est pas l'agriculteur premiers mois je
suis second la ferme puisque j'ai un
autre métier mais ma femme voilà dirige
de main de maître parce que elle a ce
côté altruiste
ou llm fédérer les gens elle aime
s'occuper des gens elle aime faire du
lien social
par rapport à nous on a quatre classes a
et ce matin il va avoir des enfants
autistes qui vont être là donc tout
compte fait 24 et aman 6 et u qui font à
bessières manquera le petit groupe
d'enfants autistes quand j'ai embauché
quelqu'un au sein de la structure c'est
vrai que en premier je regarde pas le
diplôme le diplôme pomas et par rapport
à l'animateur
c'est secondaire ce que je vais regarder
ce qu'on en a besoin c'est d'abord du
savoir-faire et le savoir-être ça se
décrète pas pour mener une équipe c'est
pas toujours évident c'est pour ça
j'avais fait le choix donc d'aller à
l'iae pour me former mais j'avais choisi
donc management association pour me
donner des outils pour aller au delà
bah voilà donc ça donne un petit peu un
petit point de vue
venez d'azir on est vrai dans une vraie
cuvette niveau géographique là on
comprend pourquoi ce n'est pas le cirque
savon au lait dans l'entrée du cirque de
cilaos donc du coup
il ya des deux côtés de l'edurant par là
qui forment cette cuvette là les enfants
arrivent donc je vais décembre
pays bas sur les tables tout puis on
vient là c'est le four à bois on est
cette personne donc le principe c'est
que chaque classe il ya un animateur n'a
eu huit ateliers tous les ateliers
touche quand même le pivot c'est
l'éducation l'environnement mais touche
par rapport à où l'animal où le végétal
mais tout est en lien avec l'éducation
l'environnement bonjour bonjour aux
autres tout
alors
alors voila moi je suis je suis mirail
c'est moi ce match d'après toi pourquoi
tu es sensibiliser comme ça ça devient
douteux
ben c'est je pense est une continuité de
haut niveau de
l'expérience tant la vie par rapport aux
cheminements professionnelle par rapport
le travail avec des enfants par rapport
des questionnements personnels des donc
un moment on arrive à une espèce de
recentrage peut dire qu est-ce qui est
essentielle et c'est pas évident d'être
le plus dépouillé possible et de faire
bien en étant plus dépouillée on est en
voilà donc ça c'est c'est un challenge
de tous les jours
si vous faites trop de bruit je fais
criquets et vous y répondez rap et
tricot
est-ce que vous avez vu comment c'est
parce qu'une à la grèce serait plus pour
que ça ait de semoule ou pas
comment on appelle la maman cochons les
enfants
une prime ou une autre
dans sa
début des années 2000 c'est vrai qu'il
n'y avait pas de ferme la réunion
bon moi j'en avais vu en métropole et je
trouvais que mon pain par rapport le
modèle il fallait s'en inspirer pour un
pouvoir en créer à la réunion qu'est ce
qu'on a comme richesse au niveau
patrimoine quand on arrive sur ce site
on a tout impact même quand on n'a rien
fait il ya déjà un patrimoine au niveau
niveau des oiseaux au niveau de la
géologie au niveau des insectes au
niveau des arbres on a tout un
patrimoine et à près de 7 ce patrimoine
qu'est ce que pas construire donc moi ce
que j'appelle de constitue
contextualiser la pédagogie
est ce que pouvait faire l'ocré de la
poule pour moi
mais combien d'animaux ou en tout cas
les poulets canards dindons doit bien
avoir
les cochons tout 300
noms d'abord vu toucher doux et les
doigts il a dès qu'est ce qu'il a sur le
dos lui
mais a des poils il a un pelage
c'est un métier mais qui demande quand
même de la disponibilité qui demande d'
opéra turquie demande des écoutes
demande en capacité aussi me sens de
partage
des choses et qui laisse la place à
l'autre aussi qu'ils allaient super avec
mireille ouais mais pensez vraiment
cette capacité-là 2 pouvoir ont serré
mener
tout en même temps laissant aussi
laissant les ans est responsable on les
sent aussi les personnes qui l'ont
emmené aussi quoi cette année c'est une
année particulière panneaux c'est une
année charnière et on a dit on a mis
cette année sous le signe de la qualité
donc
donc pour fait de la qualité on va le
décliner en plusieurs objectifs et on va
mettre en place aussi des supports pour
arriver à cette qualité avec la ferme
mince et son projet de départ et
on a monté une association les petits
bilingues bis qui du coup gère tout
l'aspect accueil pédagogique
récemment l'association salangane que
peuvent pouvoir une pédagogie
alternative ou pédagogie nos peines
ici
c'est petit il est bien par rapport à ce
que la réunion peut peut nous donner
aujourd'hui moi j'espère que dans les
générations futures ils profiteront
autant que nous on a profité nous on
aimerait bien au niveau de la flotte km
à 6 qu'elle puisse devenir ce qu'on
appelle un centre de ressources un
centre de ressources pédagogiques pour
les fermes pédagogiques de la réunion
c'est à dire que qu'on puisse disposer
d'un fonds documentaire mais aussi qu'on
puisse faire de la formation qu'on
puisse bien formés par pour les outils
pédagogiques je pense qu'on a c'est
aujourd'hui d'antériorité on a la
capacité sein de nos animateurs pour
qu'on puisse transmettre mais pourquoi
que tout ans des projets comme ça
parce que j'ai envie que les choses
changent
alors voilà déjà tout le temps je sais
je suis toujours assez pour les gens qui
sont autour de moi des fois je suis un
peu
à 200 à l'heure et en fin de compte j'ai
envie que de changer
des petites choses pour la réunion pour
nous pour nos enfants et j'ai envie que
ça change